the world hangs on the brink of nuclear
war
do you
do you think that that's overstating the
case no
that's what worried me from the
beginning and that's probably why i got
involved in all this stuff because i i
go back to the uh
60s when i was a you know when we were
so close to nuclear war i lived through
that period and i thought as as many
people did that this was
it was gonna it was gonna come now
so i've lived through that
and some i didn't sense the period in 83
when reagan took us to the edge if you
remember correctly abel archer it was an
exercise
that almost brought us to include the
russians were
really paranoid at that point and they
were they were responding to our
military exercise on able archer there
was also the korean airliner they went
down there were numerous incidents in
the 80s but i never felt the fear
i thought reagan was
testing the limits but
perhaps if i'd been younger i would have
felt it but anyway no we come close the
united states has risked this several
times
if i told you it would be hard for you
to believe if i could set a scene for
you in a drama in a in in 1962 when
kennedy has a meeting with the joint
chiefs of staff
and the uh cia and they talk
about a plan
the military plan
to uh
first strike the soviet union and china
okay it was called uh it was an
eisenhower plan that had been put into
operat put into a potential operation in
uh the
in early 60s or 50s
late 50s
siop 62
this was an attack on the soviet union
first strike this that's why the united
states has never given up the concept of
first strike
it's it's interesting that the russian
police nuclear policy posture is more
defensive than the american one which
leaves options open
it's it the same options are open in
neo-conservative uh agreements
that we see from the late 90s where they
say
the emergence of a rival power will not
be
tolerated that's a very broad statement
and it allows you to do a lot
including nuclear so
you have to understand the united states
is
always first of all it breaks so many
treaties i mean we know that from the
putin story about
the anti-ballistic missile treaty in
2002 and then the inf treaty of
the brit they broke that one that was
the intermediate
missile
that was 2019 i don't know when they
broke it off but the united states has
not been very faithful on its nuclear
agreements
and so
i don't know that we can even deal with
you i'd say so diplomatically it seems
to be impossible
now brings me to biden
yes and this is another irishman this is
the opposite of kennedy kennedy was a
catholic irish
anti-imperialist biden seems to be the
opposite he seems to be a go get along
go along guy who's been
not only old but he's also gone along
with this program which i voted for
biden because i i feared trump but i
thought biden at a certain age would
mellow i really did
he's not mellowed apparently he's still
listening to these people and he
believes them
and it seems that his uh
that horrible woman victoria nuland who
was under secretary of state appointed
her to to the to this sector of the
world she's very influential and she's
been one of the worst people on ukraine
she obviously was behind the coup she's
she was the one who boasted that uh you
know
we got our man in yachts
yatsenuk
and also
remembers the famous statement [ __ ] the
eu all these things she's but she's back
and she said the other day about
if the soviets if the russians use uh
nuclear
weaponry of any kind there's going to be
a horrible price to pay that was she was
out of the blue i said what the hell is
she doing she's talking nuclear all of a
sudden and then since that day
everybody in the u.s press all the shows
have gone talk nuclear nuclear nuclear
secretary of state has done it
blinken uh
this
it scares you if you think about it the
united states scares me
you